you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
i was at my parents place and you know
my mom's got dementia right and so i'm
i'm just sitting with her and the phone
kept ringing and i answered the phone
and it's like somebody like hey
you know it's some kind of scammy type
thing yeah and i'm just on the phone
going don't you [ __ ] call here ever
again you said that damn
dude i'm going in because i like the
mixed liam neeson yeah yeah yep it's
like reverse taken yeah
yeah
i'm coming for your daughter and i will
find you i will i will find
[Laughter]
so i just i'm always willing
and i will kill you
hold on hold on hold on through hold on
hold on hold on
[Laughter]
see my catchphrase is woo-woo your
catchphrases
no
you can't say it dude you can think it
when you're thinking you say jabberwocky
i don't say it man you guys are crazy
dude what's up ksw team it's cole out
here in eugene oregon this is what
george is going to turn
and i'm coming with a little bait club
for you
um pillows my girlfriend
prefers not to use any pillows when she
sleeps which i always thought was a
little weird she's a vampire
i'm the guy who likes three four
honestly more the merrier
um and i was just kind of wondering what
your sleeping situation was looking like
what kind of what pillows you rocking
with how many um that sort of thing um
let me know gang gang buzz buzz
what was it flock flock no listen dude
this is what you do
you get a my pillow those my pillows are
[ __ ] unbelievable you get a my pillow
have your head on my pillow you know
what i'm talking about my pillow the guy
who's really [ __ ] trump heavy and you
know
congratulations no no it's not that but
michael this guy and he [ __ ] you that
[ __ ] you'll sleep like unbelievable and
so i have one my pillow to do like this
and i have another my pillow i hold i
hold the hold it like that yep and i go
to sleep like this i just hold it like
that you go sleep on your back
sometimes and then sometimes i move over
to the side hold the pillow i'm a side
sleeper sometimes i'm going to hold the
pillow but i tell you what sleeping on
the side is better for your nose because
the [ __ ] goes to the side and it does
help a little i notice that i will even
lay my face down on the bed like this
real tight don't you sleep on an altar
so you can pray
and then turn my head like this nails
but um oh yeah yeah yeah i had my pillow
and it was falling apart the one i had
well really did you yeah really not mine
i i have a [ __ ] six on it and it
never never happens and i read the book
i read the guy's book the my pillow book
the book will put me to sleep quicker
though oh so you can read this book nice
you can read a pillow book but you can't
read okay i'm done with you i'm just
saying he offered me a book earlier and
i have a lot of books from friends like
hey this will help
but you read to my pillow book i did
it's really amazing you know what you
know guy was doing cr the guy was
smoking crack and making this company
well of course he was bro i've never
seen him not smiling oh i see why that
appealed to you but hold on this guy
is kicking the stick
yeah you have any successful crack
stories who do you send them to from
crack addict to ceo that's correct bro
and it's a good freaking book man he was
uh he would go do i i guess i could see
why i get it uh he would do daylights um
not daylight savings i don't think he
would do uh what's it called when you go
play poker just for a couple days kind
of
a tournament an addict yeah yeah he was
a gambling crack at it that changed his
addiction he was a gambling addict yeah
yeah and he would go fly out and just
play in these tournaments and fly back
and just do selling pillows and cutting
up the stuff in his garage and stuff it
was crazy wow wow it's [ __ ] hilarious
selling drugs in the was that how he did
because he he put the drugs in the
pillows yeah yeah yeah that's why you
like him you know what you can't you
know what he can't say like i've worked
hours on end i've gotten no sleep they'd
be like well bro that's your problem
you've got that pill you're not using
your own pillow yeah i mean you can't be
like he can't be like i [ __ ] stress
out because
he has to always be like i was well
rested and it would be like well you
don't work hard enough that's like the
guy that came up with atkins died of a
heart attack or whatever oh really that
kind of [ __ ] yeah that could have been
the segway guys
yeah it's like with the segway yeah oh
wow i would have been anywhere to seen
that
bad pr
that guy segwayed
right off a cliff after he bought the
company or
yeah where's segway you ever been on one
of those
no it seems like
it just seems like you're almost just
too gay to walk
that's what i feel like when i say it
sorry
also
no it would be great though if you put
something on it that made it have a
better sound
like a tesla does yeah
is that the thing you would miss the
most about not having like ferraris and
that kind of stuff is the noise i like
the noise but i don't know i would do an
electric car if they were cool i have
not seen a cool one yet so
they might um there's a cool one out
there it's mine oh really
yeah but it's not like cool cool i mean
it's not it's a cool for elec it's
always like cool for an electric car
right
i don't think it's ugly it's nice but
like
there's so many cooler cars i've been
waiting on that cyber truck but well
that that's cool it looks cool on the
pictures and stuff i just don't know
what it's going to look like in real
life yeah i know the counter the the
dashboard looks like a a
a bathroom counter yeah you might as
well have a look at look at look inside
of it it looks like a bathroom counter i
might as well have a freaking oh i
haven't seen the inside i haven't either
that's a great point let me see
look at that look at the second picture
that second picture look at that
oh that's weird you must have a
toothbrush right there
that looks ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
in the wings
you